El país del yoga… el país de Gandhi y
la no violencia… el país donde encontrarte
con tu yo espiritual… es el mismo país
donde la extrema derecha ha vuelto a ganar
las elecciones. Si creías que el ultranacionalismo
es algo único de Occidente, prepárate porque
al terminar este vídeo, Donald Trump te va
a parecer un blandengue.
India es la mayor democracia del mundo. Habéis
oído bien. Hablamos de más de 600 millones
de personas que han votado en las últimas
elecciones. Eso es dos veces la población
total de Estados Unidos. Sin embargo, seguro
que muy pocos me sabréis decir el nombre
del Presidente Indio.
Exacto: da igual que la India sea la mayor
democracia del mundo. Da igual que sea el
segundo país más poblado del planeta: los
medios de comunicación a duras penas han
dedicado un par de párrafos a estas elecciones.
Y, por eso, en VisualPolitik teníamos que
hablaros de este hombre: NARENDRA MODI, el
hombre que ha salido reelegido como Primer
Ministro Indio. Muchos pensaríais que con
este aspecto tan apacible, siendo vegetariano
y practicante de yoga, Modi es un político
espiritual, moderado y amante de la paz ¿Verdad?
Pues nada de eso. Básicamente, al lado de
Narendra Modi, Donald Trump parecería Bono
el de U2.
¿Habéis oído hablar de las vacas sagradas?
Pues es cierto, existen. Y creedme si os digo
son mucho más que una cosa pintoresca del
hinduísmo.
El llamado COW BELT, el CINTURÓN DE LAS VACAS
es una serie de estados indios donde la religión
tiene un peso enorme en la sociedad. En estos
estados existen los llamados “guardianes
de las vacas”. En teoría, su papel consiste
en proteger a estos animales. Pero, en muchos
casos, se han convertido en bandas violentas
que atacan a las minorías: principalmente
a los musulmanes. Según un informe de Human
Right Watch, en los últimos 5 años han llegado
a matar a 44 personas sólo por comer carne
de vaca. En otras palabras, que se puede ser
fanático de todas las religiones: también
la hinduista.
Y si India es la mayor democracia del mundo,
sus elecciones también son las más largas.
En casi todos los países del planeta, las
votaciones se hacen durante uno o dos días
¿Verdad? Pues bien, en India se celebran
durante 7 semanas ¿Por qué? Pues porque
en cada estado se celebran en días distintos.
Y hablamos de 900 millones de posibles votantes.
Y si las elecciones son largas, la campaña
electoral ha sido un auténtico espectáculo.
Desde la escaramuza militar con Pakistán
hasta una película de Bollywood. Sí, sí,
habéis oído bien. Además de spots electorales,
nuestro amigo Narendra Modi ha contado con
su propio biopic.
Reseña de la película sobre el Primer Ministro
Narendra Modi: Una hagiografía descarada
Con semejante campaña electoral, Modi ha
salido reelegido por mayoría absolutísima.
Básicamente, su partido tiene casi el 65%
de los escaños. Y no hay ningún partido
fuerte que le pueda hacer oposición. Así
que la pregunta de hoy es ¿Por qué la India
ha dado más apoyo aún al Partido que representa
al Ultranacionalismo hindú? ¿Hay una deriva
de la India hacia la extrema derecha? ¿Qué
consecuencias puede tener esto tanto para
la India como para el resto del mundo? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero antes,
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
TÍTULO: MODYWOOD
Mahatma Gandhi es algo más que el padre de
la patria del Estado indio. Es un símbolo
universal. Y su gran propósito, una vez conseguida
la independencia para la India, era construir
un país secular donde convivieran pacíficamente
hindúes y musulmanes. Aunque India sea mayoritariamente
hinduísta, en este país hay una minoría
musulmana. Y decimos minoría por decir algo.
En realidad, hablamos de más de 200 millones
de personas que profesan la religión islámica.
Pues bien, Gandhi y Modi fueran del mismo
estado… y ahí terminan todas las similitudes.
Modi nació en una familia humilde. Y desde
pequeño le fascinaba la política. Así que
¿Dónde se afilió? Pues a la Asociación
de Voluntarios Nacionales, conocida por la
FAMILIA SANGH. Básicamente, se trata de una
organización fundamentalista hindú con un
objetivo muy claro: los musulmanes son el
enemigo. Para que os hagáis una idea, el
asesino de Mahatma Gandhi estaba vinculado
con esta organización.
Pues bien, la FAMILIA SHANG fue el germen
de lo que luego sería el partido político
de Modi, el Bharatiya Janata Party, conocido
por sus siglas BJP. Y ya os podéis imaginar
que la ideología de este partido es de todo
menos centrista. Sin embargo, en seguida se
convirtió en una de las formaciones más
importantes de la India.
Y al calor de este partido es como Modi realizó
su carrera política. En el año 2001, llegó
a ser el Ministro Jefe del estado de GUJARAT.
Y así es como comenzó su leyenda. Básicamente,
Narendra Modi fue capaz de combinar la retórica
hinduísta del BJP con una política económica
sorprendentemente pragmática. Por un lado,
durante estos años, le llegaron a retirar
el visado para viajar a Estados Unidos y a
la Unión Europea ¿Por qué? Pues básicamente
por permitir que los radicales hinduistas
camparan a sus anchas hostigando a los musulmanes.
En 2002 llegaron a asesinar a más de 1000
musulmanes. Y las autoridades fueron acusadas
de facilitar a los radicales listados de las
propiedades de ciudadanos islamistas.
Pero por el otro lado, Modi tuvo sus luces
en la economía. Privatizó varias empresas
públicas, creó parques industriales y redujo
un montón de trabas burocráticas. En pocos
años, GUJARAT estaba creciendo a ritmos del
10% interanual. Todo el mundo veía a Modi
como un ejemplo de gestor responsable y eficiente
¿El siguiente paso? Pues, como os podéis
imaginar, con semejante curriculum, el siguiente
paso era gobernar todo el país.
En el año 2014, Modi se convirtió en el
Primer Ministro Indio. Su programa incluía
acabar con la burocracia extrema de la India,
modernizar el país y mejorar las relaciones
con Estados Unidos. Pensad que, antes de Modi,
la India estaba en la lista negra de Estados
Unidos porque habían desarrollado armamento
nuclear a sus espaldas. Modi mejoró estas
relaciones. De repente, todo el mundo estaba
encantado con el nuevo gobierno Indio. Incluído
el por entonces presidente de Estados Unidos
¿No me creéis? Pues mirad.
Obama escribe el perfil de Modi para la lista
de personalidades más influyentes de Time
Habéis oído bien. Barack Obama llegó a
ser amigo personal de Narendra Modi pese a
que no podían partir de ideologías más
distintas. Y diréis ¿Cómo es esto posible?
Pues básicamente, porque todo el mundo estaba
esperando el despegue definitivo del gigante
Indio. Y Modi parecía el hombre adecuado.
Vale, es un fundamentalista y tal vez no sea
el mayor fan de los Derechos Humanos pero…
¡Cosas peores se han visto! Y la pregunta
es ¿Qué ha hecho Modi en su primer mandato?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
TÍTULO: EL TRUMP HINDÚ
“El asesino de Gandhi fue un patriota”.
Esperad un momento porque la frase no es mía.
Estaréis de acuerdo en que ensalzar el asesinato
del héroe nacional no parece la mejor idea
para una campaña electoral ¿Verdad? Pues
esto es lo que decía PRAGYA THAKUR antes
de las elecciones. PRAGYA THAKUR es una política
del BJP. Y sí, ha ganado las elecciones en
su distrito. Al igual que Modi. Y si ninguna
de estas cosas os parece suficientemente brutal,
mirad lo que dice AMIT SHAH, que es nada menos
que el presidente del partido.
Amit Shah jura que arrojará a los inmigrantes
ilegales al Golfo de Bengala
Ya os dije que al terminar este vídeo, Donald
Trump os parecería un blandengue. Y esperad
porque todavía no habéis visto nada. Y os
preguntaréis ¿Cómo es posible que Narendra
Modi y su partido arrasen en la India de esta
manera? Una palabra: economía. En este respecto,
Modi se parece bastante a Erdogan, el presidente
turco. Los dos son extremistas religiosos,
los dos han tenido buenas relaciones con Estados
Unidos y los dos han presumido de buena gestión
económica.
¿Qué decís? ¿Qué no conocéis la historia
de Erdogan? Pues os la contamos en este vídeo.
Y si queréis descubrir lo que ocurre en el
mundo, no olvidéis suscribiros a VisualPolitik
y darle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Pero sigamos con nuestra historia. Durante
el gobierno de Modi, la economía India ha
seguido creciendo a un 7%. Su administración
ha conseguido sanear las cuentas creando impuestos
indirectos parecidos al IVA. Y este hombre
se ha labrado una imagen de hombre humilde,
trabajador y, a la vez, hábil para los negocios.
Pero como decíamos antes, el peso de los
radicales en su gobierno ha sido muy importante.
Y básicamente, les ha abierto la puerta de
las instituciones.
Actualmente la familia Sangh domina la policía,
el ejército y la Justicia. Pero sus tentáculos
van mucho más allá. Controlan la escuela
privada más grande del país. 5 millones
de niños están bajo su influencia. También
posee fuertes vínculos con otra organización
fundamentalista que protagoniza noticias como
estas:
Los activistas de Bajrang Dal golpean a un
niño musulmán por ir de compras con una
niña hindú
Así que, como podéis ver, el avance del
fundamentalismo hindú en la India está alcanzando
cotas preocupantes. Y digo fundamentalismo
hindú porque la ideología de Modi va mucho
más allá del nacionalismo. Por ejemplo,
su gobierno no han perdido un segundo en ofrecer
la nacionalidad india a los inmigrantes ilegales
que proceden de países musulmanes como Afganistán,
Bangladesh o incluso Pakistán. Siempre que
cumplan un requisito: no ser musulmanes.
Es decir, que el radicalismo del BJP no es
sólo nacionalista sino también religioso.
Sólo quieren que queden las religiones propias
de la zona como el hinduismo, el budismo,
el jainismo y el sijismo.
¿El problema? Pues que en la India siguen
teniendo 200 millones de musulmanes. Suponen
el 14% de la población. Y, creedme, su vida
no es fácil. Y diréis… ¿Cómo les oprimen
exactamente? Pues volvamos al ejemplo de las
vacas.
Antes de Modi, las vacas eran animales sagrados
mientras se mantenían productivas. Cuando
envejecían y dejaban de ser rentables, las
autoridades hacían la vista gorda y acababan
en los mataderos, que normalmente son negocios
en manos de la población musulmana. Gracias
a esto, la carne de res terminaba siendo alimento
para esta minoría.
Con la llegada al poder del BJP, en muchos
estados se está prohibiendo el consumo de
carne de vaca. Es más, el gobierno de Modi
ha gastado casi 90 millones de dólares en
construir las llamadas GOSHALAS, que son albergues
religiosos para vacas. En estos albergues
se cuida a las vacas según los principios
del hinduísmo y se promueve el vegetarianismo.
Por supuesto, todas estas medidas son un ataque
a la comunidad musulmana, que en muchos casos
vivía de criar vacas para consumo humano.
Pero, para muchos fanáticos, esto no es suficiente.
Pero los radicales hinduistas todavía quieren
más. Y por eso, en la India ocurren cosas
como esta.
Un informe concluye que los vigilantes de
vacas en la India mataron al menos a 44 personas
/ Aproximadamente 280 personas heridas en
más de 100 ataques durante 3 años.
Os lo decíamos antes, se puede ser fanático
de muchas religiones.
Y alguno pensará: bueno, mientras la economía
siga llendo bien ¿Qué más da? Bueno, pues
lo cierto es que la gestión de Modi en este
sentido también deja bastante que desear.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
TÍTULO: CORTINAS DE HUMO
El 30 de enero es el Día de la Paz en honor
de Gandhi, pues ese día fue asesinado. A
estas alturas, estoy seguro que ya pensáis
que cualquier paralelismo entre Gandhi y Modi
es pura coincidencia. Si Gandhi era un símbolo
del activismo pacifista, Modi es un auténtico
pirómano.
Sí, es cierto: la India sigue creciendo.
Pero eso no es mérito de Modi. En realidad,
la India lleva creciendo desde hace décadas.
Pero también crece la población. Y lo que
no crece tanto es el empleo. Sobretodo entre
la gente joven. El paro juvenil en la india
en máximos históricos. Y su promesa de crear
10 millones de trabajos se ha quedado en agua
de borrajas.
Tampoco están de buen humor los agricultores.
El Gobierno de Modi aumentó las importaciones
de productos agrícolas y redujo las exportaciones
para bajar los precios. Esta medida ha sido
buena para las grandes ciudades pero los agricultores
se han visto afectados.
Pero sin duda alguna, el gran fracaso económico
de Modi ha sido su lucha contra el dinero
negro. De la noche a la mañana, el Gobierno
retiró de la circulación el 80% de los billetes.
La idea era obligar a todo el mundo a usar
tarjetas de crédito y transferencias. De
esta forma, no podían evadir impuestos ¿El
problema? Pues que no todos tienen cuentas
bancarias. De repente, la gente se agolpaba
en las sucursales de los bancos. La mayor
parte de las entidades no sabían muy bien
cómo reaccionar. Y ¿quiénes fueron los
más afectados? Pues las clases bajas que
tienen negocios modestos en los que normalmente
se paga en efectivo: una frutería, una barbería...
cualquiera que imaginéis.
Todo esto significa que Modi podía perder
la mayoría absoluta. Al menos, eso es lo
que pronosticaban muchas encuestas. En cualquier
caso estaba claro que ganaría las elecciones.
Pero parecía evidente que tendría que pactar
con otros partidos.
¿Y qué hace un político fundamentalista
cuando su estrategia económica no funciona
del todo bien? Pues lo mismo que ha pasado
con Erdogan.
India frena el poder de Amazon y Walmart para
vender productos en línea
Pero ya os hemos indicado que si en algo es
experto un pirómano como Modi es en crear
cortinas de humo. Y para ello, nada mejor
que avivar aún más el orgullo de ser hindú.
Como os hemos explicado recientemente en este
video
La India de Modi ha realizado su primer ataque
aéreo sobre Pakistán desde hace más de
40 años como respuesta al atentado de Cachemira.
Por fortuna para el planeta, el conflicto
no ha ido más allá y no ha desencadenado
una guerra entre dos potencias nucleares.
Pero a Modi le ha venido de perlas. En enero
de 2019, las encuestas decían que perdería
la mayoría absoluta. Y ahora, 5 meses después
y con un conflicto con Pakistán de por medio,
Modi ha arrasado en las elecciones. Repito:
su coalición roza el 65% del parlamento.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros.
¿Creéis que Modi está jugando con fuego
con su estrategia nacionalista? ¿Conseguirán
su objetivo los más radicales de reemplazar
a Gandhi por Modi como el gran héroe nacional?
¿De verdad puede Modi sacar a India de la
pobreza? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita. Es muy
importante lo de la campanita para que os
lleguen las notificaciones. Y ¿Cómo vais
a perderos los vídeos de VisualPolitik? ¿Dónde
si no, váis a conocer lo que ocurre en nuestro
querido mundo? ¿eh? ¿Eh? Desde luego, en
el canal de Dalas Review no. Así que venga,
todos a darle a la campanita. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!